voulait aussi revenir bien sûr avec toi
sur le dossier des agressions sexuelles
dans le patinage artistique dans la
porte en général parce que juste
j'aurais qu'on revienne sur la une de
charlie hebdo
charlie hebdo qui la semaine dernière
s'attaquer directement une célébrité que
tu connais bien puisque c'est nelson
monfort regarde regarde ils avaient fait
leur une sur nelson monfort a entendu
parler même la une de charlie hebdo tu
l'avais pas vu la une fait référence aux
scandales sexuels dans le sport et
sous-entend que les journalistes
sportifs dont nelson monfort aurait été
au courant
donc voilà des accusations assez graves
contre nelson on va voir la une
voilà si j'arrive à le retrouver ces
charniers et d'autre que nelson aurait
tôt pour agression sexuelle tant que je
suis dit là dessus sinon c'est fait ça
me conneries ça perd vraiment personne
mais tout con non l'agression sexuelle
est le viol par rapport à ce cas qui
s'ouvre leur gueule journaliste sportif
avec nelson monfort voilà qu'est qui est
là qui est qui rend qui ont une voix la
façon personne n'était au courant du
geste jusqu'au viol en fait par rapport
à ce que racontent et sarah l'envol donc
nous on a tous été surpris donc ça
m'étonnerait que nelson a bien sûr été
au courant alors nous 5 février 54
athlètes de haut niveau ont signé une
tribune pour dire stop aux violences
sexuelles dans le monde du sport est
donc didier gailhaguet a finalement
démissionné c'est nathalie péchalat qu
est la première candidate officielle
pour le remplacer qu'est ce que tu vas
la soutenir alors natal est parti un peu
en solo sur ce dossier là d'accord parce
que nous on avait un groupe de réflexion
qui on se posait plein de questions dont
sarah abitbol fait partie nathalie
évidemment été cordialement invités mais
s'est pas sentie invité donc elle l est
pas venu nous rejoindre et du coup elle
a dégainé la première en dix ans je me
présente à caen comment pour la
candidature de la présidence
donc ça nous a coupé un petit peu
l'herbe sous le pied du coup on est en
train de regarder aujourd'hui comment
soutenir en fait sa candidature parce
que nous nous sommes des athlètes c'est
une athlète c'est une championne comme
nous tous a envie de la soutenir ou tu
es tu sûr qu'elle n'a pas envie d'aller
contre elle en fait ah ouais la soutenir
le problème qu'elle soit partie un peu
tout seul ça nous pose un petit souci
déontologique il aurait préféré un autre
candidat
vous êtes appelés on s'est téléphoné
pour le moment à nous a pas présenté
need équipe ni de programme à vivre
encore quelque part c'est compliqué à
l'annoncé ya pas si longtemps que elle
voulait rien changé à la fédération
actuelle nous c'est pas parce que ce
gars est gay a démissionné parce qu'on
souhaiterait cki une grosse partie c'est
ce que souhaite le ministère aurait été
une grosse partie en fait des gens qui
sont restés très longtemps à au sein de
cette fédération que ça change
pour ça il faut changer les statuts pour
changer les statuts il faut des gens et
malheureusement il faut des gens
nouveaux
bien sûr parce que même où ça fait plus
de vingt ans qu'on attend d'être invité
par la grande porte de cette fédération
qui a été notre maison mère qui nous a
formés à devenir des champions et on
nous invite pas rentrer à l'intérieur
alors on nous dit ouais mais vous les
champions voulait arriver et prendre
tout de suite la présidence bah en même
temps j'allais dire que qui connaît
telle et telle personne du monde du
patinage il faut des gens représentatifs
ce n'est pas qualifié pour tous les
postes de la fédération il faut quand
même des gens qui soient l'acquis social
qui s'occupe des affaires fort à toi
t'as pas envie de te présenter
mais alors le problème moi c'est que je
pars en tournée avec koné nice 14 le 14
mars c'est la journée où il ya les
élections pour l'après l'aurait fait si
l'on a sinon j'aurais fait parce que
toute façon c'est le moment où dans deux
ans j'ai que je vais avoir 50 fils je
pense que c'est le bon moment pour
redresser plus ce qu'on a pris un petit
peu dans la gueule quand tu vas faire
des trucs parce que sa forte écoute dit
aux présidents de clubs qui peuvent être
assurés si c'est moi qui me présente
d'accord j'ai pas encore officialiser ma
candidature et je sais pas encore si je
vais y aller et commence à chauffer je
suis en train de chanter a dit réfléchir
à bangkok la même temps on n'a pas envie
d'aller contre la candidature de la tête
avaient opéré c'est bien qu'ils
deviennent présidente pour dargaud râler
et quelques brasiers
il est à la défense nathalie ou pas je
pense qu'elle est bien soutenue en fête
à la reithalle a déjà des appuis c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'elle avait gagné la
première bombe a très bien mais coûte en
tout cas on va suivre ça l'an